learning how to help is a very important
part of water safety and there's three
things you need to learn how to help
yourself how to help others and how to
help your environment when it comes to
helping yourself make sure you remember
and follow everything you've learned so
far if you do these things you'll stay
safe on the beach but if you're not on
the beach there are other things you can
do to stay safe too if you can't already
swim for example you could take up
swimming lessons or join a life saving
club to make you a better swimmer and to
teach you how to carry out a safe rescue
that will certainly help you in the
water and lifeguard Club teaches
youngsters and adults life-saving skills
and awards yeah we'll help them and
others if they ever get in trouble if
you're looking to get involved in water
sports either here in the planet area or
whilst on holiday we recommend you look
for a national accredited or a proof
training center like the surf school we
have here at jos by but it's not just
people you have to look out for I need
your help to look after our environment
too and we aren't the only ones living
around the coast especially here in
planet
all kinds of coastal birds and marine
life use planets beaches it is also
important that you know how to treat
these animals both for your safety and
for theirs for many of them the
coastline is their home so we all have a
duty to make sure don't drop litter more
than anything for beach
you should always remember to put your
litter in a bin or even better you can
take it home with you and recycle your
rubbish vanets coastline is an important
feeding grounds for many different
species of birds that migrate here in
internationally important numbers for
the winter one of the birds that spend
its winters here is the turn stone you
may have spotted them resting together
at places around the coast such as here
at Margaret's Harbor on at high tide or
at night they spend the summer in Canada
and the same birds return to the very
same Bay year after year but if they are
disturbed too often during winter they
will burn off lots of energy and not
have enough fat stores to fly back to
Canada for the summer if we give the
turnstone space they'll continue to
enjoy our coastline for many years to
come infinite's we also have large
numbers of gray and common seals living
around the coast they can be found on
the Goodwin Sands margate offshore
sandbanks or
in the last hour here we can see the
signals from ordinary boat trips that
run from Ramsgate swing harder and by
far the safest way to come out of view
the seals will be on an organized trip
on a boat and rather than trying to
approach them from the land if you try
and approaching from the land the school
seals which is scatter the good thing
about coming out on a boat it is very
safe for you and it's very safe for the
seals as well you know it may not be
every day that you come across seals or
other marine mammals on the beach but
they do occasionally become stranded
along many Afghan its bays especially
during winter you should try not to feed
stranded seals and definitely don't try
to return them to the water phone 999
and ask for the Coast Guard the Coast
Guard will arrange for local marine
experts to come and safely return them
to the sea or take them to one of the
local animal rescue centres where any
injuries will be treated before being
released back into the sea one of the
local seal rescue centers is the RSPCA's
malla dams Rescue Center in Hastings if
a seal is injured it sometimes comes
here until it is well enough to be
released back into the sea
you
you